To design algorithms, we need an
abstract model of a parallel computation
and a way to write down the algorithm.
This lesson is about one such model,
which is sometimes called
the Dynamic Multithreading Model.
It has two parts.
The first part is that a computation
can be represented by a directed
acyclic graph, or DAG,
sort of like this one.
Each node is some piece of
computational work or task.
Each edge is a dependency
which says that a given task
can't start until all of its
predecessors have completed.
Now, from the point of view of
exploiting parallelism, a good DAG is
one that has relatively few dependencies
compared to the number of tasks.
After you learn how to analyze
abstract DAG's more precisely,
we'll arrive at the second
part of the model.
It's a pseudocode notation, or
a programming model, for
writing down the algorithm.
This notation will be defined so
that when you execute one of these
algorithms, it generates a computational
DAG, at least conceptually.
Now, one caveat before we start.
You may have done multithreaded
programming already
using libraries like P threads or
Java threads, where your program
explicitly creates virtual threads and
then assigns units of work to them.
If that's the case,
you need to forget what you learned,
at least for this lesson.
The pseudo code notation that we'll
talk about separates how to produce work
from how to schedule and execute it.
That means that you focus on creating
an algorithm that has a nice DAG.
Separately from that,
there will be a physically multi-core
machine and runtime system that
given your DAG figures out how to
map it to cores and execute it.
Now there will be some limits to the
kind of DAG you can produce in the model
we'll describe but I hope you'll see
that it's still a really natural,
elegant and powerful way to
express a parallel algorithm for
a broad class of interesting problems.